first of all i'm wearing a little chilly
here in l.a i'm wearing this winter
sweater
check out this feature right here look
at that don't i look like uh
like from the 1950s a sci-fi villain
[Laughter]
merciless what's that ming the merciless
ming the merciless from buck rogers i
believe right yes that's true
yeah i don't know look what do you want
got the pandemic still going that's all
i got is i'm wearing kind of a sweater
and i noticed seconds ago that it could
do this
and that became my opener that's the
world we're living in
get used to it wonderful show though jay
barachel
is going to be joining us and uh he
wrote and directed his own film
it's very good and we'll be talking to
him and of course my old friend andy
richter
still here how are you andy i'm i'm
still here you know that's for sure
i'd say i don't know about you but i
honestly find
this stretch of the pandemic to oddly be
the most agonizing in a way because
i i think it was the hope i think
towards the end of the year
yeah that there's a vaccine that's
rolling out and everything's going to
change and
i think january and february has just
felt
i mean so far anyway a little bit of a
downer
yeah and we're also coming up on a year
yeah you know we'll be coming up on a
year of this we're all depressed but we
shouldn't be
because i got this sweater that does
this
look at that
it was then that o'brien's career
shifted we call it his zipper sweater
phase
would that be was that an uptick or a
down tick uh
it was it was considered a weird tangent
for a few years